[Music]
they're back in would you look at those
smiles
meagan Markel and Prince Harry stepped
out at Canada house near Trafalgar
Square on Tuesday marking their first
public engagement of 2020 and official
return to work the couple looked
refreshed and relaxed holding hands as
they greeted well-wishers before
visiting Canada's High Commissioner
Janice Charette they were at Canada
house and to thank the High Commissioner
for what was clearly a wonderful holiday
well it's wonderful to have the Royals
back
not to mention Megan's fashion the
Duchess looked radiant in a Massimo
Dutti brown satin skirt a turtleneck
sweater by H&M and Jimmy Choo valve it
pumps she completed her look with a tan
Stella McCartney pea coat a royal source
Thole tea that the Sussex is returned to
the UK this past weekend after a seven
week stay in Vancouver Island where
we're told
they were able to recharge and enjoy
family time according to the source the
trip was quote breathtaking this is a
couple who when they want to go to
ground really are experts in going off
the radar
they were only spotted when they were
out hiking so they were keeping a low
profile they were staying at the house
of a very wealthy friend of theirs so
they were clearly able to to go to
ground and to keep themselves to
themselves and stay below the radar no
details as to how they got to Canada
whether or not they flew private jet and
no trip to Los Angeles like we
originally thought there had been quite
a lot of speculation that they'd be
spending Thanksgiving in the US with
Megan's mother Dorie well they were with
Toria Raglan but they were actually in
Canada and they've been in Canada for
the whole time so Thanksgiving Christmas
and New Year I think it's safe to say
they are big fans of Canada
sobic in fact there's speculation that
the Sussex is 2020 agenda could include
a royal tour of the great white north
the trip to Canada House today is
unusual and it's prompted a lot of
speculation as to whether there is
perhaps something more to this visit are
we going to get an announcement in the
not-too-distant future that the couple
will they're going to Canada on an
official royal tour we sure hope so
because a royal tour could also mean
more Archie sightings I think we might
see more of Archie in 2020 if there's a
royal tour the Sussex is are going to be
focused on launching their new
foundation they're going to be busy with
engagements Archie's going to be in
child care of some sort so don't expect
to see a huge amount of him but if this
tour possibly to Canada or somewhere
else happens overseas this year then I
can't see them doing a tour without
Archie
[Music]